[Music]
mr. Zuckerberg would you be comfortable
sharing with us the name of the hotel
you stayed in last night no
if you've messaged anybody this week
would you share with us the names of the
people you've messaged the senator no I
would probably not choose to do that
publicly here hi welcome to another cold
fusion video the biggest tech companies
wield a lot of power these days there's
some of the most valuable companies in
the world but it's easy to forget how
quick and meteoric their risers have
been Facebook Google and Amazon were all
founded after 1994 while fellow tech
giants like Apple and Microsoft they
seem to have been around forever were
only founded in the mid 1970s but while
money brings power this new breed of
global leaders has much more than just
money or power they have your data it's
a relatively new commodity and the rise
of Technology has given these companies
and precedented information about us now
data is perhaps the most valuable
commodity in the world nowadays a
question is being asked are these
companies able to responsibly handle
such power and do they have too much
power and among growing fears of the
tech giant's influence of power over the
population and the market there's a
growing movement to break up the big
tech companies so what have the tech
giant's done to get to the stage and
what does the government plan to do
about big tech and how will this affect
all of us this is the war against big
tech and we'll have all the answers in
the following video you are confusing TV
[Music]
generally speaking competition is good
it drives companies to innovate where
Jesus cost and produces better products
as they compete to be the consumers
first choice ultimately the consumers
benefit from this however if a company
has too much of its share of the market
it can use this to its advantage
squeezing out smaller competitors or
only using this power to unfairly
manipulate the market in its favor the
classic old-world example is a big
supermarket chain putting the local
mom-and-pop stores out of business it's
one of those times where everything must
go
as they say all good things must come to
an end for 45 years we've been a small
mom-and-pop hardware store it's story
similar to many other small shops the
big boxes just kept pulling customers
away due to their size they can buy
products cheaper and then ramp up prices
later when there's no competition this
is called antitrust and it's the main
reason why there's a government war
against big tech however other factors
such as the power that companies have
over the population and the sheer
control of everyone's data are also
important motivating factors Facebook's
power to discriminate on free speech has
been argued to have impacted on the
development of political ideologies
within the population even mark himself
has said that he and the Facebook team
have too much power over speech Facebook
does have a board of directors but mark
owns the majority of the shares
unlike the leader of a democracy there
are no checks and balances on Facebook
mark has no boss and he cannot be fired
further to this scandals like Cambridge
analytic I have exposed the ways that
Facebook monetizes people's data but it
goes further than this
recently Facebook has announced their
own currency in the form of Libra coin
it's been met with strong reactions by
both the public and regulators
extrapolating into the future the
integration of Libra into Facebook
services could see the company gain
direct control of the most fundamentally
powerful asset that we have in society
our money for most of the world money is
a matter of eating that day or going
hungry so one can understand the
reluctancy of people to allow Facebook a
private company to control not only our
data but our money too in this early
stage a lot of people say that it's not
going to happen but really it could be
as simple as Facebook and their many
corporate partners offering 50% of
anything bought with Libra coin Facebook
will then take that loss such a move
could be enough to get early adopters to
join and then the momentum and critical
mass could follow shortly after and this
isn't to mention the primed readiness of
developing markets imagine this you
traveling to a country but you end up
being rejected because of your social
media posts this happened to an
individual traveling to the United
States in August now imagine that you
become denied your ability to purchase
goods with a Libre style coin that
everyone now uses perhaps you violated
Facebook's Terms of Service on hate
speech it would really be a new world
and you can clearly see why some people
are calling for action you know this is
a $20 bill do you know who can who can
use a $20 bill I believe the answer to
your question is Everett anyone
everybody can use a $20 bill deeds the
this $20 bill doesn't discriminate on
anything you could be a murderer you can
say horrible things you just say great
things this $20 bill can be used by
every single person but quickly who gets
to use Calibra and Libre can Milo you
innopolis or louis farrakhan use Libre
congressman never bring that up because
you know both those two individuals have
been banned from Facebook so this is a
question that is really important to get
right congressman and we
written the policy yet see and that's
what concerns me I love what you're
doing but when we say we at Facebook are
going to set the social policies of who
can use that is cryptocurrency well what
I fear is maybe in a roundabout way
what's happening in China with their
social scoring you you get the right
social score you can get a loan you get
an apartment maybe Facebook is doing the
same thing here where if you meet our
social standards that's the way you
access the network so we have to conform
our behavior to the standards of
Facebook to be on the network where I
think the right hands would be listen
everybody if you're if you're abiding by
the law has access to this system Apple
is in the middle of a class-action
lawsuit for inflating prices in its App
Store as it's the only way for people to
buy apps on iOS we've talked in depth
about Apple's case in a previous episode
and as you've seen there this could
really put them in trouble meanwhile
Google and Amazon's listening technology
in the form of Google home and Amazon's
Alexa have sparks inquests into whether
that data is being used for advertising
purposes or even worse recording private
conversations imagine the leverage he
gained over someone if you recorded
everything that they ever said Google is
also under fire for using its market
position to favor its services of other
competitors for example favoring Google
ratings over Yelp ratings in their
search algorithms and while all these
accusations are going on Amazon has been
accused of killing other companies with
unfair practices now big tech companies
have all this power so are they going to
use it for the wrong reasons and further
to this is this all too much power for
any one company to hold the United
States government does think that these
companies have too much power and
they're going to go to litigation war
over this
[Music]
Google about to find itself at the
center of a major antitrust
investigation within two dozen states to
announce a coordinated antitrust
investigation into Google this afternoon
now the focus will be on whether large
tech companies have engaged in behavior
that stifles competition restricts
access and harms consumers now they're
making this announcement in front of the
Supreme Court which appears to be
sending a message that they are not
going to back down from this fight I'm
told this will be a bipartisan effort
two bodies hold the authority to carry
out antitrust investigations in the
United States these are the Department
of Justice and the Federal Trade
Commission or FTC
right now they're engaged in a
discussion to decide who will carry out
the inquiries into big tech companies at
this stage it appears that the
Department of Justice will carry out the
Google probe while the FTC will
investigate Amazon and Facebook
proceedings are ready moving quickly
against big tech YouTube was recently
find 170 million dollars for violating
children's privacy Facebook was fined
five billion dollars in a record FTC
statement over their privacy practices
to make things worse it was recently
revealed that Facebook exposed 400
million phone numbers of users amongst
this backdrop a fleet of Attorneys
General launched an investigation into
Facebook and Google starting on the 9th
of September the case will cover
potential harm to consumers from
Google's impact on digital advertising
the fate of all of these investigations
and outcomes is very complicated
especially with the layers of legal
process the FTC for example defines a
monopoly as a company of the market
share of more than 50% and in the case
of big tech companies this may be
difficult to determine for example
Google has a minut share of the cloud
computing market but there's certainly
the first choice in terms of internet
searches Google has already been fined
5.1 billion dollars by the European
Union for breaking antitrust as for the
rest of the cases against big tech with
the US government's legal armies Google
has mentioned that they'll be
cooperating with the government but
Facebook so far has remained silent
only 41% of the public said that they
trusted the big tech companies will do
what's right for their users and the
economy the fact that people lack the
trust in these services you still find
it hard to leave is perhaps one of the
greatest signs of overwhelming power
that these companies have amassed in
their control of the market
there are many possible outcomes from
these investigations the most realistic
is that the big tech companies will hire
an army of lobbyists and lawyers to
fight any resulting cases in the end if
any wrongdoing is found
they'll be slapped with some fine and
new regulations may be put in place but
all will be forgotten in a few more
years but what if this doesn't happen
what if these companies are actually
broken up all this mean for you well
this is a complicated question in the
past companies were relatively simple
take the example of Standard Oil it
produced and sold oil its market share
was massive so when it was broken up in
it was simply divided up into 34 smaller
companies each with their own production
facilities and networks but how do you
break up a complicated company that just
doesn't do one thing how do you break up
Google or its parent company alphabet
they do internet search advertising
consumer electronics cloud computing
online services and much more where are
the lines drawn well FTC chief joe
simmons has recently said that he's
ready to break them up if necessary he's
on the record saying quote it's not
ideal because it's very messy but if you
have to you have to end quote his agency
has opened its facebook investigation
and if it's required undoing Facebook's
previous mergers and acquisitions might
be a reality that means letting go of
whatsapp and Instagram undoing these
mergers while extremely complicated
might reinvigorate competition allowing
consumers to benefit increased
competition in the instant messaging
market is arguably dominated by Facebook
messenger Instagram messages and what's
their messages which are all owned by
Facebook
now if these entities were separate
companies they would have to try and
compete by spending more money on
developing their product or decreasing
the number of ads to make their app more
appealing and that's a good thing
they'll now have to put in the effort in
order to make a better product usually
with more competition consumers win
there may be some disruption though
imagine if YouTube have to be split off
from Google right now YouTube isn't
profitable or it's just breaking even as
it stands so it's possible that YouTube
as a standalone company might collapse
on its own
no current litigation is focusing on a
monopoly on video sharing but it's just
an example of how landscapes could
change so what does this all mean for
you and me it could mean a great shift
in our relationship with large tech
companies we're at the stage in history
where were seriously questioning the
intent of the companies which he raved
about for so many years the companies
that brought us the Internet in all its
glory the companies that brought us the
tools that revolutionized society were
asking the questions of what is
considered fair in this new technocratic
landscape and just what it means to have
too much power we're starting to realize
the value of our data and what it could
do in the wrong hands but more
importantly we're now writing the rules
about how big text should behave with
such rapid advances in technology and
most of these companies going from
startups to world leaders in a matter of
a couple of decades we may only get one
chance to write the rules so who do you
think will win the war big text lawyers
or the government's fleet of attorneys
general let me know what you think in
the comments section below so thanks for
watching the video don't forget to check
out the cold fusion podcast and follow
me on Twitter and Instagram
if you want to see more stuff on science
technology history and business there's
plenty more where this came from on the
channel so anyway that's it from me this
has been to gogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys
[Music]
[Applause]